Good morning John.
Amsterdam is very good,
I wanna have a lot of different thoughts from this place.
Thoughts about tulips,
and financialization,
and economic bubbles and genetics.
Thoughts about how some clogs seemed quite big
until I saw others, and then
...This....Wow!
Thoughts about how there's a freaking fair in the middle
of this town right now
sharing space with 400 - 500 year old buildings
and fair food is pretty much the same everywhere.
"I asked for American sauce
because I figured it would be ranch dressing...
but it's not.
I do not know this flavor."
But of all the thoughts I could have from this place,
guess what I spotted while casually Google mapping around
to see what there was to do....
Oh ... a bench.
The Fault in Our Stars Bench,
on Google Maps, with 75 reviews,
and an average rating of 4.3,
which is just as good as the Van Gogh Museum.
John,
I assume that you are equally as fascinated
to find out what people say, when they review a bench.
Which is why this video is going to be mostly people's reviews of the TFiOS bench.
"It’s just a bench!"
"It’s a bench!"
"Honestly, it’s just an ordinary bench."
Though apparently that was worth four stars.
"It’s...
bench.
That’s it."
Some don’t even think that it’s a particularly good bench.
Milena, in a two star review says
it’s extremely uncomfortable and she doesn’t know how Hazel and Gus did it
and Dominika remarks on the bench’s aesthetic, I think, more than its cleanliness
when she says that people need to treat it better.
It does appear to be the opposite of the largest ball of paint,
in that many tourists seem to remove paint every time they go, rather than add it.
But of course, there are lots of great reviews of the bench.
Marciano says that there are a few promise locks
which have apparently multiplied substantially in the last 8 months
because this is more than a few.
Maharlika says that it was really fun to try to recreate the famous movie poster
and suggests that you take a picture from the other side of the canal,
which is how they did it in the movie.
That is an excellent tip!
Katarina deeply disagrees with all those remarking on the bench’s lack of comfort
saying: "10/10 Would sit again".
Joanna agrees saying, best free attraction in Amsterdam,
visited twice in one day, five stars.
Though to be fair, there are no other free attractions in Amsterdam.
Now, none of these reviews really encapsulated my experience with the bench,
so John, I left my own review.
Here it is:
"My brother wrote a book, that made a bench, famous enough that is has seventy-five,
now seventy-six reviews on Google.
That’s really weird, and also amazing.
If you’re just wandering around Amsterdam,
there’s a pretty good chance that you’re going to accidentally come across this bench.
It’s a fine bench, but ultimately, it’s just a bench that is in no way special,
except because of what people bring to it.
I guess that’s like most important things, and also people.
We aren’t much, unless you know our story.
I sat by this bench for a long time watching people come up and take pictures with the bench,
some of them didn’t seem to care that much and were just looking for something to do between events
but others were clearly excited to interact a bit with a physical space that was important to them,
or to their relationships.
There were a lot of friend groups and a lot of couples.
It made me happy.
My brother is a little bit obsessed with road side attractions in America
and it is very cool and very weird that he unintentionally inspired a canal-side attraction across an ocean.
Each person brings to this thing
their own stories and their own connections.
Each person
makes it a little bit more
than it was ever meant to be.
Again,
maybe, a little bit like all of us.
John,
I’ll see you on Tuesday."
(all): Good morning, Hank it’s Tuesday!